we just got back from doing a week shows
at comic-con which is really fun yeah so
many people so many people go to
comic-con just to scoop up toy
collectibles from their favorite movies
and TV shows well I I got a great
collectible this weekend in San Diego
I'd like to share with you right now
it's a rare mint condition la bamba and
he's still in the box let's bring it out
[Applause]
there he is originally issued five years
ago the box lebombo is a real
collector's item with all the original
accessories
there's his trombone - extra hats summer
picnic la Bamba and Blood Wedding
lebombo a pair of maracas and the
extremely rare lebombo blade of justice
oh yeah best of all it's a talking
lebombo doll they didn't make many of
these he's says all of Obama's favorite
sayings in English yeah another one my
heart and my head is full of crackers
okay I want more hello ladies
goodbye bladder control very nice there
you go don't make this soap in such
pretty colors if you don't want me to
drink it okay
shoes are like pants on your feet okay
see if there's any more but we did the
japanese-americans was wrong
this hat holds exactly 2 cups of beef
stew very nice that's the good condition
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography